[Music]
this video is a response
to a joke a supposed
joke that a comedian made
about the christ church event which took
place last year
whereby 52 people were horrifically and
monstrously
uh killed in their place of worship
let's
hear the joke and let's hear the
justification
for the joke this australian extremists
stormed this building this mosque
this room where people were saying their
prayers and going about their business
and for me the saddest thing about that
it wasn't the 52 people who were killed
it wasn't the countless others who had
their lives changed forever because
their family members were taken from
them
it was the hundreds of people that night
who couldn't make it home from
nightclubs in christchurch because all
the cabbies were dead
[Applause]
so in trying to defend his views
this comedian has come out with a range
of
arguments really of justification so
let's hear the first one
key word there is it is a joke
it is not real it is make believe i
don't really feel like that but that is
what comedy is
what i've got here is the dictionary
definition of what it is to be a joke is
something such as a funny story or trick
this cambridge
dictionary that is said or done in order
to make people laugh
your criteria of uh the joke having to
be something which is
um or assumed to be something which is
fictitious or
make believe it's not something which is
indicated with the dictionary definition
i've looked at more than one dictionary
definition
so why is it that you want us to assume
that
a joke is something which is make
believe fictitious or doesn't correspond
with what you believe in
doesn't make sense it's not in line with
the definitions i have so the problem
with this joke
is not just the fact that you
trivialized or minimized the plight of
the 52 people that were killed in cold
blood
yes and the families of those
individuals who are also grieving and
probably still grieving at this moment
at such a horrific and monstrous event
in the history of the world
it's not just this fact but it's the
fact that you homogenized
this group of muslim people as if they
are one ethnic
group all of which have one occupation a
singular
occupation which is what taxi driving
taxi driving
when in fact islam and muslims are a
diverse
group of individuals and the people who
died were different genders in different
ages let's let's be frank
you might be saying oh this is pedantic
it's a joke no sorry i don't this does
not work with me
it does not work with me because the
word joke here yeah and what it means to
be a joke is not this what you what you
try to put forward and fool your
audiences with
it's not that so having said this now
not only is that the case but you
you made it as if those individuals who
are now homogenized and otherwise
yeah those muslims who are the taxi
drivers have the sole job
of taking people away from taking people
home from nightclubs
living a liberal lifestyle a non-islamic
lifestyle so here the point is this is
that not only have you homogenized
and otherwise the muslims but you have
made them the servant class
the slave class whose job it is
to facilitate the liberal lifestyles of
those people who are enjoying themselves
in clubs and pubs uh out
on that night and that is for you the
tragedy now you might be saying
it's not why i actually believe it's a
lie it's make believe but that's not
what it is to be
a joke and we're gonna explain why your
sacred values and i use those words
clearly
of freedom of speech absolutism is in
fact
flawed in what follows but we laugh
about horrible things all the time it's
how people deal
with tragedy and he even says in another
part of his video that we i he himself
made a joke about the holocaust and
about 9 11.
it's not about you a white man yeah that
lives in australia making a joke about
9 11 or this or that so but imagine if a
muslim
yeah a practicing traditionalist muslim
had made a joke about 9 11.
that's the comparison the comparison is
imagine if a traditionalist muslim who
is clearly visibly
practicing his religion yeah made a joke
about nine that's the that is the
correct kind of comparison
then how would the the the public the
american public react to that
and would they have a right to react
angrily to that that's the question it's
not about whether you
as a white man who has no connection to
the to islam or
muslims yeah make a joke about 9 11 on
the whole of course it's about
whether muslims make that joke practice
visibly traditionalist
practicing muslims make that joke yeah
and whether that could be or would be a
response which i i'm pretty sure they
would be
in england or usa or whatever it is
it is just laughing at horrible things
and i understand why you're offended
because i'm offended by it too that is
the point
this is problematic because in the
beginning of this whole video you were
showing us screenshots
of people uh abusing you online
cyberbullying
so if you really thought if you really
thought
that being offended should not be the
criteria
for people saying or not saying some
things why are you even showing us the
abuse that you suffered
why are you even showing us that if you
really thought that this was the case
why are you showing us the fact that
these people were saying
mean spirited things to you online
who cares if you felt offended by that
so really it's one
uh standard for yourself but another
standard for the community which you
think is a disposable one which i think
you're learning is not which is the
muslim community
if you treat me with respect i will
treat you with that same respect
and then a minute 5 40 you talk about
respect
as if you we're gonna really listen to
you yeah it's really let's be real
i mean that's the joke if you want to
make a joke you want to make a joke
yeah that's the joke that you are going
to start talking to us
about all of after all you've done about
respect
what is the what is the definition of
the word respect due regard one of the
definitions is
do you regard for people's feelings so
if you have respect for me
you're talking about reciprocity and
respect that if you have respect for me
i'll have respect for you and vice versa
and so on
but what if we're telling you right that
what you're doing is disrespectful
and you continue saying i'm gonna do it
so is that is that respectful
according to what respect actually means
so you seem to be a contradictory man a
contradictory man
a man who hasn't got his morality
figured out this is the problem
intellectually you're bankrupt you're
morally bankrupt
you have no sense of direction when it
comes to what can i say and what can i
not say
i genuinely believe that everything is
okay
which means you're a free speech
absolutist
but society even liberal thinkers
okay liberal thinkers who argued the
case for freedom of speech
they would restrict and censor freedom
of speech
as per the harm principle on certain uh
occasions for example plagiarism
copyright
um leaking industrial secrets
of government for example military
secrets these are all
examples um of i'm sure if someone took
your video and put it on
on their youtube channel you wouldn't
like that and you might even say you
know what this is not the kind of
freedom of speech
yes i accept because this is copyright
and plagiarism
otherwise you should make a video
explaining to everyone that you allow
your content on their channels
you should do this if you are truly a
free speech absolutist
but you will say no it's copyright and
plagiarism and so on and so forth
and if that is the case and if that is
your position then you realize that
there is a need
a practical need yes a practical need
for some kind of censorship
so if you realize that there is a
practical need for some kind of
censorship in order for economy
and society to move forward
the question is who sets the parameters
for such need
where does it become inappropriate or
otherwise immoral
for certain things to be said or not to
be said
and what the contradictory set of
propositions you're putting forward is
there is nothing sacred and that is the
way
that comedy should be but the irony the
mother of all ironies is the following
is that for you comedy is sacred and not
only is that
not only is comedy sacred but free
speech is sacred as well
you're saying nothing is sacred but you
actually are upholding a sacred
principle
in fact you could even argue depending
on how you define religion a religious
principle
yes that free speech
should be upheld which is in my
understanding of it
a sacred principle don't make yourself
out to be a neutralist
when it comes to uh free speech and so
on and so forth you do
prioritize and hierarchies yes you do
that
a set of moral propositions over and
above other moral positions
don't say ever nothing is sacred because
clearly you're upholding
free speech absolutism as a sacred
morality and not only that but comedy
itself is sacred for you
so much so that you allow
things to be said in the name of comedy
that you would never probably allow
to be said in other contexts for example
copyright libel defamation of character
and so on and so forth
my question is how do you make such
distinction
on your moral philosophy how do you make
such a decision
how can you prove that on the one hand
yeah if you take functionalism out of
the picture
how can you prove that it's immoral to
plagiarize
and defame and on the other hand yes
on the other hand it's okay to say
whatever you want in the name
of comedy the problem here is you
actually
do have a god you do have a god
you do have a religion don't make
yourself out to be some neutralist
or some agnostic in this sense no your
religion is the
religion of liberalism and more
particularly
free speech absolutism that's your
religious what's sacred to you
okay so having said that now nothing is
sacred would make
no sense at all particularly the muslim
people who think i'm a horrible piece of
[__] you want to see me burn
well you said that some muslims you see
this is the problem
hasty generalizations muslims according
to pew by the end of the century will be
one of every three people
on planet earth demographic one of every
three people a third of the planet will
be muslim
i don't think all i don't think you've
done a referendum yes
on 1.8 billion people and in fact the
quran itself says in chapter 4 verse 147
that what has what with allah benefit
what would god benefit
with your punishment if you are thankful
and you believe
and god is ever thankful all
knowledgeable
chapter 4 verse 147 in fact if muslims
are are doing what islam says or what
the quran says in particular they
shouldn't want you to be burned at all
muslims should yes according to the
quranic discourse
want the best for you and in fact that's
what i'll say to you
we don't want you to go to hell in fact
the opposite is true we don't want
anybody to
be burnt or go to hell or have a demise
in the afterlife which is eternal
eternally excruciating we don't want
that to happen to you
in fact we want you to have a
pleasurable eternal
life of goodness and that's why we
invite you to islam we invite you to
believing
in one god as the quran says in
shakhartom
to be thankful and gratitude grateful to
be thankful and grateful
to god and to believe in god and with
that you'll have
the ultimate purpose of life realized
the ultimate purpose of life which is
not to make
other people laugh that's not the
purpose of life i'm not saying you
shouldn't or you couldn't
you can do that as well it's a
subsidiary thing but the
the crux of the basic human function is
to believe in one god
to worship one god yeah for the sake of
knowing your purpose having a happy life
having welfare in this world and in the
next world we don't believe that you're
just gonna
turn into ashes and that will be the end
of the human experience
so that's something you should look into
and i and i invite you to look into
that in fact i'm having happy to have a
conversation with you and bring you onto
my podcast the mh podcast
where we can have a conversation a
religious conversation
a political conversation a philosophical
conversation
about these things free speech about
religion
about what you actually meant and in
that way
perhaps the muslim community can look
past your ignorance towards them
and perhaps we as humanity
can move forward together hand in hand
not offending one another and as you
said
in theory respecting one another but
also in practice
implementing such respect to another
you